scheiß drauf scheiß drauf scheiß drauf
bist du bis hinter mir naja fließen wie
wird man reinkommt comcom jetzt ergeben
herzlich willkommen zur folge find ich
cool
wir machen also direkt angreifen
matthias brändle jetzt jetzt verstehen
dass sie angreifen dass sie anderswo
gucken was von drüben canucks holy bauen
sie schon in die mitte
ich freue mich vor ja alles alles alles
in welchen der mitte übertreiben mal
alles gut ski dir alles gute
heftig jäger das ist alter schwede ok
boss überfordert mich immer ein bisschen
was ist ein richtig ist minecraft spiel
minecraft
trotzdem kam das aber kommt glaube ich
so oder so was nicht ein wassereimer ok
auf routern platzmitte
wir müssen aber jetzt nicht sterben mein
name ist minecraft sagst ja nur
erweiterte da können wir nicht durch die
post europas hoch ja ich versuche
zumindest ganz ruhig bei mich richtig
hoch
hoffentlich einfach keiner hier in der
nähe oder schneeball oder so sondern
können wir soweit ansonsten wird es
nichts mit dem zuweilen warte ich bin
nicht direkt unter der vorsicht ich kann
ja nicht halb überlebt nein da und dort
drei und drei belegt man unterschlagen
alter scheiße kommt ich noch mal im
cockpit noch mal schnee weil ich lieber
durch die wälder ruft passen alter
auftakt auf dem wasser du kannst du
kannst water machen das geht nicht ganz
gut
nur welche kopp kann ich halt nicht so
wirklich weitergeht aber kopf webdesign
full diane welche auch ich nicht so ich
habe glaub ich bin dir aber mit coaches
nimmst du wasser alles was damit sehr
gut ok man kann jetzt aber hat mich
gerufen alter kommt das wasser unten an
ja das kommt und dann glaube ich so was
einfach riskieren aber haben wir eine
chance haben wir eine chance gerade vom
bäcker ich warte ich papier wasser hin
man warte jetzt fließt das erstmals
beide weglassen ttt jungen a ist leger
sehr schön oder alter junge heftig aber
jetzt jetzt ist denn die erste adresse
aber egal egal hast du level zufällig
welches spiel wir nochmal lassen
entstand abbauen das geht sogar junge
gut mitgedacht denken war
genau deswegen was für ein wahrer
partnerwahl immer mitgedacht hast wenn
ich auch immer
spielen freundin komm hoch wir werden
weiter leben egal egal leute konstant
genug um einmal das ist mir erst später
eingefallen das wollte ich unbedingt
eigentlich niveau folge ein stein aber
ich hab's vergessen was wo bist du von
rokoko wurde ich kenne er meinte sie
also ärzte und gegner gekillt also der
mainz kind darstellt und er meinte er
werde als guter mensch wiedergeboren und
so oder so genau wer aber dachte ich mir
so minecraft zwei games und ich mache
jetzt einfach gerne ganz richtig
behindert aktion ich kräfte mich jetzt
einfach hoch von holz spitzhacke auf
einem stein spitzhacke und dann auf eine
eisen spitzhacke und dann mache ich mir
dann brauche ich mir hier die dias ab
minecraft erst geredet ich hab' ich habe
erfolg kraft da bekommen ja ich heiß
computer wo bist du
ich bin da nicht nehmen soll ich mache
ja der war noch ein bisschen eisen und
dann die idee ist mit über 31
schweinsteiger und thomas müller
vielleicht auch nach thomas mann
angeblich auch von renate gekauft werden
100 millionen ist das alles 31 denkst du
es gibt im fußball eine loyale person
ich glaub ich glaube auch nicht glauben
gleichheit nicht was eigentlich überlegt
mal das sind fußballspieler und wie viel
geld sie bekommen eigentlich ist der
bislang die kommen die conti kommt er
zurück ich muss zurück zu uns und ja
diese nicht bei uns
jetzt geht's ab insgesamt und
schnittmuster
da kommen sie auf akku faktor aber
welche leute rausziehen raus überlegt
über den jungen
ich hab sogar weiter kills bekommen die
beste leben als text halte sie die hits
weg ist so bruder ich bin ein richtiger
big mac ich brauche noch zwei dies
erkennt man erst machen
ich habe dir hast du oberliga perfekt
erläutert ihm junge reisen mit dem da
kann uns vielleicht noch einen amboss
kräften
ich habe noch sechs als okay weil ich
noch ein bisschen anders
mit 2 level kann ich zwar schade dass
die lg schwerte verbinden zum beispiel
ja aber ja genau aber da brauchst du
auch zwei ich hab es als ich hier
passierte haben wir das level müssen
aufpassen kann wie viele gegner haben
eigentlich noch 3
dann lasst ihr mann holen ja sie ein die
einen sind e10
wo sind die unter eines alleine die sind
ja man weiß es hat nicht mehr
man weiß es hat nicht nur 22 reisen
jetzt hier noch sechs reisen okay dass
einer da wo genau gerade aus hieß es
der hat auch wenig lust und das
rüberkommt ok hoffe ich hatte keine
schneebälle lieber gott bitte stehen uns
bei ok attacke gut gewinn geben leute
wir sind auch gerade nachts um halb drei
am aufnehmen so als kleiner agierte
anekdote oder sind doppel sind dort zwei
egal drauf drauf drauf scheiß drauf
scheiß drauf bist du bis hinter mir naja
warten statt wasser etwas herunter
fließen
scheiße wie wird man reinkommt comcom
jetzt jetzt jetzt pakistan heißt nice
nice gewinnt gewinnt gebiet gewagt
ergebnis erheblich um scheiße sehr
schöne weste leben weiter läuft man ihn
hoffentlich was kann ich sie schlagen
eigentlich gut wir können uns am ende
nicht
ich habe glaube ich daraus noch die us
gesehen jungen die runde ist echt nice
wir sind so gut ja man da habe ich
tatsächlich dir gesehen richtig spaß ja
richtiges manche sogar gold ab ohne
willst du das echten mein spiel jetzt
suchen wir mitarbeiter in ihrem kompass
und lade dir ist mitgenommen hatte man
warte man jetzt kann ich ein sms machen
kann ich wenn ich auf reisen krieg und
ich hab mir weisen dabei wo bist du viel
kohle mitnehmen hatte ich bei uns doch
kurzreisen da können wir ich habe noch
einen leistbaren ja immer job alles
machbar hier klar
dann kann ich uns hier kann ich jedem
fan es machen heisterkamp spam gegen den
letzten to be one to be one sp geld und
aber leben retten der effekt und als ob
hier kommt man nimmt da der macht gar
nichts wusste überhaupt gibt distanz
sind das nicht ich weiß nicht mehr jetzt
ok ok aber was machen wir natürlich die
mitte bauen oder wie oder ja also redet
der laster linksrum links und rechts vom
papier dann geht es war irgendwie ein
lover oder so was man nutzen kann
nicht mehr so oft du four ok perfekt ja
da hat er richtig schöne runde man zwei
drei richtig knappe kämpfe und jedes mal
gedreht
loch im boden bis 13 ich habe richtig
schiss hat oder so faymann
oh ja das ist so schlimm bei diesem
scheiß ja du bist ja direkt raus so böse
das ist wie bei großen bett oder wie
minecraft mein kopf war oh mein gott
minecraft warum ja deshalb vorne ist
läuft vorne
ok frau sich immer auf den boden schauen
nicht runter vom superstar dsds da sei
es dann warte kombi gold auf 1 cic aus
der welt der haute ihn einfach wieder
aus der welt bei es wunderbar schön
geschnitten glatt die runde gewonnen war
aber ein ding bevor ich wollte da nicht
fehlen aber etwas geht immer egal scheiß
egal warum warst schon check karte auf
jeden fall ab falls ihr noch nicht kennt
super kanal wirklich jemand sehr guter
zahlen dieser kanal auch gut besetzt um
die themen wirtschaftspolitik und
asylpolitik und nach stopp des und
verlinkt wie sehen die nächsten wir
wieder rein mach's gut und